je suis sous peu le printemps de bourges
des chanteurs triés sur le volet mais
ils ne sont pas les seuls chaque année
300 agents logistique sont recrutés pour
encadrer l'événement une sélection
ouverte depuis quelques jours en
extérieur vous via aussi du filtrage et
de l'accueil et de l'orientation
personnes une description du poste
d'agent d'orientation guider les
quelques 80 mille festivaliers en
musique
de quoi attirer ces étudiants et jeunes
demandeurs d'emploi ça risque quand même
aussi un petit plaisir je me fais dire
ça comme ça qu'est ce qu'il ya comme la
musique la côte est
on travaille en même temps donc quand on
envoie aussi du monde c'est pas pareil
quand postillons et 30 bureaux tout seul
avant tout pour trouver un emploi et
surtout pour financer mes études
salariés et retraités peuvent aussi
postuler une obligation remplir ce
formulaire de renseignements tous les
profils sont acceptés il n'y a pas du
tout prérequis particulier ceux tentés
d'avoir 18 ans puisque bien évidemment
des postes on propose également aux
soirées ennuis donc il faut que ce soit
en adéquation bien évidemment avec le
code du travail
résultat trois cent cinquante neuf
candidatures déjà reçu triés en fonction
de certaines compétents la langue
étrangère je ne vous cache pas que c'est
plutôt l'onglet qui m'intéresse pour
être totalement honnête et surtout grâce
à un test de personnalité
c'est important pour nous de savoir
comment on va pouvoir réagir la personne
est ce qu'à un moment donné en fonction
de la situation va pouvoir prendre les
devants apporter une solution ou est ce
qu'elle va pouvoir être plutôt en
retrait être dans une posture dit calme
et pouvoir apaiser la personne
l'adaptabilité la clé pour travailler au
printemps de bourges
les candidatures seront acceptées
jusqu'au 1er mars